nous y sommes au cœur de votre projet de
loi déclaré irrecevable par notre peuple
la mobilisation est massive la levée
populaire rappelle les grandes heures de
l'histoire sociale de notre pays
monsieur le ministre il vous reste la
légalité institutionnelle mais vous avez
perdu la légitimité sociale nous ne
pourrons plus poursuivre le débat de la
même manière qu'hier votre texte est
massivement rejeté nous le savions tous
depuis le 19 janvier date de la première
journée de manifestation et de grève nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens n'ont pas
lâché ils sont aujourd'hui plus nombreux
encore dans l'action c'est un
raz-de-marée contre la réforme
profondément injuste de Monsieur Macron
et de son gouvernement nous l'avons dit
répéter comment avez-vous osé provoquer
le pays ainsi s'il y a blocage si nous
sommes dans cette situation de crise
sociale majeure monsieur le ministre aux
côtés sous le contrôle du président de
la République
la première ministre vous emportez
l'unique responsabilité votre obsession
libérale votre pensée dogmatique vous
ont poussé à la faute vous êtes tombés
dans votre propre piège dont vous aurez
bien du mal à vous sortir vous n'avez
plus expliqué au travailleur qu'il soit
salarié ou non pourquoi ils devront
s'user à la tâche plus longtemps portez
la je l'égale du départ à la retraite à
64 ans n'a pu passer car tous ont bien
compris que notre moyen existent pour
financer le régime des retraites par
répartition d'autres solutions dont vous
n'avez pas parlé à commencer par mettre
à contribution les richesses
considérables de la grande puissance que
nous sommes main dans la main le
président de la République et la
majorité sénatoriale dans l'affichage
enfin de cette union des droites veulent
imposer la destruction d'un pilier de
notre République la sécurité sociale
écoutons le peuple écoutons pour une
fois le peuple
soutenez mes chers collègues notre
demande refuser l'âge de départ à 64 ans
merci chers collègues
alors quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez merci madame la Présidente mais
c'est strictement interdit jour appelle
mes collègues un peu de respect quand
même pour l'assistance s'il vous plaît
vous voulez peut-être toujours fait moi
je vous dis c'est interdit madame la
Présidente assassin j'en suis désolé
voilà la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur non n'est pas la parole même
la présidente on n'est pas la parole
pour l'instant maintenant la Présidente
je lui ai donné la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur
je suis en cours de parole c'est bien
parce que
le rapporteur merci Madame Liliane
[Musique]